[Music]
this is your first time performing here
since that horrific incident what's it
like for you to be back here man you
know I think everybody's sort of tried
to make this you know this thing about
me coming back to Vegas kind of tried to
make it a little bigger than it was you
know for me that you know I've got a
million great memories in Vegas you know
and one horrible one but for that one
horrible when I have a ton of great ones
man I you know a lot of career
highlights for me happened here so I
love this town I mean I love Las Vegas I
love the city and you know was looking
forward to coming back out here and and
and I think this is the right setting
for me you know to be out here with the
country music family you know my friends
and people in the country music world
and you know so I think this is you know
the environment for me if we're gonna do
this I think this is the right way to do
it the first time and but you know but I
was excited man I was I was excited to
get back out here and you know I said
man I love the city and always have and
you know I had one obviously tragic
thing happen when we were here but but
I've had a lot of great things happen to
me here too let me ask you one last
question on that and we'll talk about
the new album just a week after the
massacre you performed on SNL and you
performed Tom Petty song I won't back
down
did you realize how cathartic that would
be for the whole country uh you know I
think we knew that us you know
performing on that show and if we did it
the right way would be a you know a big
thing for everybody I think everybody
was sort of you know needing something
to sort of say okay man it's okay to to
start the healing process now and and
that was our biggest thing going on SNL
was I remember having the conversation
with with Lorne Michaels and those guys
and just being like you know they called
him wanted us to do the show and I just
said you know if you guys will let us
come and I can say what I want to say I
can play the song I want to play and I
can do all this stuff my way then I'll
absolutely come and do it but I don't
want you guys writing stuff for me to
say or any of that so I I wanted to make
sure that it was my words and what out
my message that I wanted to get across
and you know and to their credit they
allowed me to go in and do that and and
so you know I felt like that was sort of
a you know not only a healing moment for
me but it was also
chance for me to sort of tell everybody
else like you know this is horrible and
it's you know but it's it's okay to
start the healing process and start to
pick up the pieces and move on so I
think that was big not only for me but
for everybody else
[Music]
[Applause]